Let's go through momentum in 60 seconds.
Momentum is a product of mass and velocity.
Momentum is also a vector quantity.
This means it has both a magnitude
and a associated direction.
For example,
an elephant has no momentum when it's standing still.
When it begins to walk,
it will have a momentum in the same direction
as it is travelling.
Faster the elephant walks,
the larger its momentum will be.
Momentum can be calculated using the equation
where momentum is equal to mass times velocity
and the equation triangle can be seen below.
Momentum is measured in kilogram meters per second,
mass is measured in kilograms
and velocity is measured in meters per second.
Let's go through this example question together.
A lorry has a mass of 7,500 kilogram.
It travels south at a speed at 25 meters per second.
Calculate the momentum of the lorry.
The first thing we do
is write the equation that we need to use.
We don't know the momentum,
but we do know the mass and velocity.
And if we do mass times velocity
we will find our answer is 187,500